so I think my first visit is a bit of a
blur but it was a long time ago
it was definitely when I was a student
it would have been in the sort of mid
90s and I came as a student and I was
looking at all the architecture of
Cambridge and Boston and MIT and you
know very special pilgrimage to come to
this chapel because I'd seen it in
photographs it was incredibly
inspirational to me and my thesis work
so I wanted to finally see this building
that I understood sort of sectionally
and you know atmospherically it was
really special during my master's
program I was I became very interested
in working on a faith-based space and it
was one of the sort of thesis studio
projects and I looked at lots of
examples of which there's so many of
course around the world and I was
particularly struck by this little
chapel at MIT I struck because it
proposed a section and what I mean by
that is the kind of the slice through
the building the way in which it's
constructed that I'd never seen before
and I try to understand that and I read
what the intention was and I became
really fascinated by it why would you
spend so much energy and effort doing
something that was contrary to the way
in which most people would make a
building and when I came finally to the
building it it revealed its its purpose
very clearly because when you are here
with light and the water it's a very
powerful space and you understand the
pretoria you understand the vessel you
understand the texture it all comes life
some of the particular features that
really struck me and made us a very
strong impression was a building which
used the elements to directly affect the
emotions of the function of the building
so you know when you normally make a
building it's you know you use materials
for performance functionality and
Durin's you know all those somethings
aesthetics you know visual pleasure but
I think here sarahdan did something more
he actually also marshaled the natural
elements to evoke a more powerful
emotional feeling
in the building by using water and by
creating a building which is hasn't a
relationship to the story you know it's
the sort of the notion of sort of a
Christian life it's this idea of a kind
of Arkham vessel so in a way literally
we're sitting in a vessel on a water
body and he makes he makes that analogy
really really close and I don't think I
never seen that in architecture before
so it was quite profound I love the
contrast between the outside and inside
of this building um I think for most
people from the outside it probably even
looks like a you know a power station or
something but I mean I think it's it's
clearly not it's more than that it is a
very astute port portioned sort of
gentle full stop in the landscape it's
almost like putting a perfect dot at the
right point but it and it understands
that that's all it needs to do and in a
in a space which in a way could almost
be multi-denominational it really is
let's base there yes it was designed as
a chapel Christian sense but it's really
at almost a kind of multi-faith space in
my mind he's very careful to to put in
signature but also to create a kind of a
notion of a different kind of building
that's being celebrated here which is
different to an academic building or a
campus building so it's very close on
the outside it really speaks about the
inner world not the outer world and I
think that even if you don't know the
out language of architecture I think
intuitively that's there and then you
really you find yourself elevated on
this bridge the you know the walkway is
not through a standard door that you
come up to there's this pond that float
that's sort of around it and you look at
the water and you look at the pond and
then you and I think you have to bridge
into it so you you really have to take a
journey from the outside to the inside
and it uses all the devices that make
that narrative clear
and you know when you come in it's you
are not disappointed the inner life of
the building is extremely rich it's
varied its emotional it's inspiring yeah
I think what Saarinen is really trying
to do is to create a very particular
counterpoint to the campus generally and
he's making a really beautiful full stop
what I call a full stop
you know I think the importance of a
full stop in a sentence is really
important and if the campus is the
sentence this is the full stop that
makes you pause now what I mean by that
is that it's a kind of proportion
geometry sort of pile of brick that has
a very particular position and and in
weights I'll stare on the outside but I
think that austerity speaks to something
that sarahdan understood which was that
there's a bigger community than just the
prince christian community here and i
think he was trying to signify that this
is a faith space or a different kind of
space of space of the inner world rather
than the outer world and I think he
reinforces that even more I mean people
think it's castles and and such like but
I think it's it's really using
architectural sort of systems to really
speak to a way of making construction in
the 20th century that speaks to
traditions so this idea of making a
building which is literally hovering
above a body of water the water is a
pond of course and it's it's wonderful
from the outside as a reflecting system
but it activates the interior of the
building very dead dynamically and then
you come across not so much a moat
because that's kind of to do with
defense and security it's really in a
permanent bridge and it's this idea of
elevating and you know you sort of and
why is it a special Brigette's you're
surrounded by this kind of colored glass
you know it's really this idea of moving
from the kind of spectral light of the
outside to a very kind of focused sort
of spectrum of light and color before
you enter the main chamber and you see
this incredible volume where I was like
a baroque Chapel you know the walls are
undulating with life
and you're sitting you something when I
sit you're sitting in a chamber which is
disconnected from the from the exterior
because suddenly there's light kind of
coming upwards light doesn't come up
with like a dowel so he's really
emotionally sort of channeling sort of
things that are not what you
traditionally find in a modernist
building and he's using narrative
narrative implicit within the notion of
faith that narrative implicit in the
idea of transitioning from an outer
world to an inner world to really make a
very powerful building just when you
think you think you understand how a
material can you know is perceived in
the world I think a great artist or an
architect can take that very mundane
material and make it magical or let it
have another message and I think what
you're seeing in this sarahdan vessel is
the way in which rejected bricks you
know the things that are at fault I
brought to play in this volume in a
really profound way so they're rejected
bricks which would normally be thrown
away from this a brick foundry because
it's all about the perfection are the
things that are celebrated and giving
articulation to the volume you know
instead of bringing in new technology to
make acoustics he he articulates the
brick skin to allow it to also absorb
sound and not be a kind of live space
but to be a kind of really important
space that allows concentration of the
mind so that the single material is
being asked to do a lot of things both
functionally and poetically and
metaphorically and it transcends it's
very kind of mundane nature and I know
that's a very special quality the
atmosphere of the of the of the chapel
is is articulated and in a very powerful
and precise way it's it's a reduction of
material so what you just see is the
brick and and then the wooden vessel
sort of the Bannister that wraps around
at the
level and I think the wooden banister is
the metaphor of the boat so immediately
this whole notion of being entering the
vessel is articulated by this banister
and it's disconnection from the brick
which is the world in a way and then
really this notion of how light is
articulated is is very powerful around
you the light comes from below you sort
of reflected reflected but at the altar
it's a it's a very singular sort of Zen
at all sort of focus almost like a
spotlight on the on the on the on what
the minds focus is supposed to be and
it's the only daylight that's allowed to
sort of stream from above and and it's a
kind of wonderful moment where Pretorius
sort of commission Pretorius commission
to make an extraordinary sculpture and I
hear the sculptures purpose is really to
slow down the like right it's sort of
just to make it visible to the eye I
mean of course it's visible but there's
something about the way in which the
petals of pretoria sculpture capture
almost as it were fragments of the light
and sort of hold it hold it still for
your eyes to gaze upon does this
incredible thing of slowing it down
almost making it look like it is
descending like a shower that's a very
powerful thing so that's what you have
is this building made out of brick wood
and light yeah I think Saarinen is
really careful to really understand the
nature of a sacred building and a
profane building and I think that that's
the duality that he really puts out in
the middle of this campus then he talks
about being able to understand it near
the nature of the sacred and profane and
in a way this is the sacred vessel which
is the intimate space and the space of
debate and discussion is the whole
question Hall and that is more like a
tent right it's more like a stretched
tent a gathering space for everybody to
come to it's multi-directional there's
no front or back really I mean there are
doors in one place but the idea is that
visually it's multi-directional and in
the heart of it is this great auditorium
which collects and gathers people it's
made very much with the same kind of
materials as break-ins and timber but it
has obviously the copper on the outside
but I think this idea of the sort of
chamber and the tent are this sort of
dialectic that siren gives us a gift to
the MIT campus to talk about this
duality and it's very poetically very
powerful I think the chapel of course
has a relationship to the brick of
Boston and I think Sarah that's very
clear about that but I don't think he's
trying to make sort of memetic
references or or anything like that I
think he he uses brick because brick is
simply the humble material it's the
mundane material and I think he's very
interested in how does he take a mundane
material and make it transmit
transfigures that literally transfigures
it with with nature with light and with
geometry and proportion so I think that
you know it's meant to be singular but
from a contextual point of view you can
also see how it completely fits within
the Boston landscape within the MIT
campus I think that it's it's always an
important charge for an architect or an
artist or designer to be able to use any
material and to not see inherent in the
material limits but to see in any
material the possibilities so for me I'm
you know what siren doesn't break I'm
very inspired by in my own work in that
I'm very interested in using materials
that you just disregard in your mind's
eye is not being precious or valuable
and I'm interested in reconfiguring
those to represent the value of that not
to be sensational or to just just to be
you know just to be alternative or
anything like that but just to really
talk about the preciousness of matter I
mean that's kind of I think the deep
sort of thing behind it is that this is
got a deep respect for matter on this
planet and things that are made things
there from the planet formed or reformed
sort of and this idea that everything is
precious and not about a kind of certain
hierarchy you know a certain stone is
not more precious than you know
composite for me or you know etc etc
it's all valuable and all should be
given the kind of dignity of being able
to transfigure into something that
inspires I think that the urban planning
and
architectural departments at MIT are
very lucky to have a gift these two
buildings really present this sort of
some of the key components of our of our
societies in the sense of you know are
introverted world's the sort of secular
and the the sort of faith-based world
and the public world you know and I
think Saarinen gives a gift to MIT and
to generations of Architects you know
and he makes two timeless structures
that are really going to be inspiration
inspirational for generations to come I
think these two buildings as we move
into the centuries that are coming are
going to become even more powerful as
icons about you know how we make
buildings the idea that the chapel is
here on the MIT campus which is a kind
of science and technical based sort of
institution really speaks to this notion
of understanding the spirit in in
science that there's a kind of there's
also a kind of you know this notion of a
of a spiritual space or spirituality is
not about unknown things it's also about
the kind of wonder of the world as well
and to be to be ever present and aware
and then or about how beautiful it is
and how powerful of this and I think
that the chapel creates that
counterpoint to the sort of searching
research which is about uncovering the
world but also a space to kind of
reflect and to to take in the world take
him in the kind of vastness of the world
and it also in a way to understand that
there's a lot done but there's also so
much to do it's sort of a wonderful it's
a wonderful meditative chamber
you